ازمه دبلوماسيه جديده بين طرابلس واثناء
اثرها هذه المره وزير الخارجيه اليوناني
عندما رفض استقباله من قبل نظرته الليبيه
كانت وزيره الخارجيه والتعاون الدولي في
استقبال وزير الخارجيه اليونان وفقا
الاعراف الدبلوماسيه الا انه في موقف
المفاجئ يدعو للاستياء رفض الوزير
اليوناني نزول من طائرته وعدم حيث اتى دون
اي اضاحات وزيره الخارجيه في حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه المؤقته قررت استدعاء السفير
الليبي لدى اليونان للتشاور كما استدعت
القائمه بالاعمال اليونانيه في ليبيا
لتوضيح خلفيات الحدث الاجراءات اشاد بها
رئيس الحكومه المؤقته الاحترام المتبادل
اساس العلاقه الدبلوماسيه مع دوله اليونان
لن يسمح بهذه التصرفات تجاه دوله ليبيا
وسيادتها
من جهتها اكدت اتنا ان الغاء الزياره جاء
بسبب خلق ليبي للاتفاق بشان اجنده الزياره
الى طرابلس
الرئاسي لانه وزاره الخارجيه خرقت اتفاقا
بعدم الاجتماع بهم وستتواصل زياره الى
شمال ليبيا كما هو متفق عليها
طرابلس منذ توقيع الاخيره مذكراتي تفاهم
عام 2019 مع تركيا تتعلق احداهما بالتعاون
العسكري والثانيه وهي الاكثر اثاره للجدل
بترسيم الحدود البحريه انقر اكدت بفضلها
حقوقها في منطقه واسعه في المتوسط وفي
اوائل اكتوبر الماضي وقعت طرابلس هو انقره
اتفاقيه اخرى للتنقيب عن المحروقات في
المياه الليبيه
يونانيون مصري سريع